sleeping around different for men and  for women actually i don't believe in a  double standard but i see if you're  single do it but you still look down  upon aren't you i think it's different  for women because we carry more of an  emotional attachment to it whereas men  they just do it for the sake of doing it  okay see like this here when you're a  woman someone's putting it inside you in  it so so that's unit like that's that's  your sort of space but when it's someone  else it's a man they're just going in  and out they're going to the next one  you know what i mean so it's like for  goals it's more man it's like do you  know what i'm saying i agree